oh I'm getting a psychic signal from my
lawyer is copyright census there's a
disturbance in the copyright everyone
their mother has done this video already
but I'm doing it now and therefore I
claim ownership over it this is now my
video and anyone else is copying me this
is knockoff markiplier merch we bought
this well Amy bought this a while ago
before the whole lockdown happen I've
just been putting off making this video
for no particular reason but I am
equally outraged as I am now as I would
have been then should I be outraged we
will find out if I'm supposed to be
outraged because this merch is knockoff
of my own merch which I sell exclusively
for charity and I'm willing to bet that
the people making the knockoff merch are
not selling it for charity where can you
get your you can get my official merch
at markiplier com that's ma RK i p li ER
dot c om
but in a world where there is supply and
demand and glorious consumerism there's
always a need for bootleg merch bootleg
definition being that boot over there I
have a leg where didn't bootleg come
from sounds piratey you know a piratey
because you're stealing [ __ ] yeah that's
what it is I I should make it clear this
stuff is not from red bubble it's not
print-on-demand it's not fan art this as
far as I know is straight from eBay and
Amazon what I mainly have a problem with
is people duplicating designs that I
already sell for charity on markiplier
comm and selling it for profit
that's what I have a problem oh my god I
haven't seen this design in ages uh it's
so old at this point it's so incredibly
old ya know I sold this very briefly way
back when this was a Spreadshirt design
that I had I forget who made it I'm sure
credits on the website where you got it
from you don't need to look both ways
when you got swag though the word swag
has not been uttered it since 2014 you
don't need to look both ways when you're
Wow when you got clouds when so yeah
this is a design from 2012 not even 2013
like I don't hearken back to 2012 era
markiplier because it's the first year
that I started because basically nothing
happened except the original fall of
Slenderman which this is from soon after
our interview markiplier was hit by a
bus his last words you don't need to
look both ways when your gosh why I'm
actually gonna keep this as a classic
but hey cut that [ __ ] out my lawyers
will be in touch
unless it's like stocked like backlog
from my original Spreadshirt I have no
idea let me try I'm gonna try to do some
own try to go - markiplier that's
Spreadshirt comm editor lick seeing hi
how you doing you're beautiful man
could you please if I find this I'm
trying to go - markiplier that's bread
sure calm nope marklar swag shop is what
it's called them there are no products
to show because I closed it down a long
time so if this was obtained it was not
obtained through me you can go ahead and
put up a picture of that good thanks
Lucy
thank you thank you
I'm gonna sue you out of existence not
you licks in
sorry nah nah Oh what is this what the
hell is this oh it stinks it's it's got
that print-on-demand screen-printing
smell to it
oh so you'll often hear me quoting this
cuz it's such a powerful statement some
here oh well it's not all heroes wear
capes they didn't even get the stamen
right you are never alone mine wear
headphones see what this says is it not
only dates it as a design because this
is pre hair color so it's like 2014 but
also how is this still selling cuz it
must be right like this is still saw
someone somewhere this is their rent
payment right someone had the ideas like
merch they've got a warehouse somewhere
they've got a screen printing company
they don't ask questions there some
person sees these faces every day and
maybe they take a little joy out of it
maybe they look at it early or maybe
they just hate the look of these two
[ __ ] which i think is the more
likely cause one the stink bad to the
design old three it looks like a wanted
poster you know what I mean
the yellow tacks the top about it this
would be a wanted poster from a distance
if you're like squinting your eyes
people that reward here did if wanted
dead not alive this would be a wanted
poster so not not great not can't say
but at least it's not one of my designs
- I know it's so stanky ya know it the
pretreatment that they do on these
things I'm very familiar with it it's
it's pungent anyway do I give that one a
10 what do we have stickers right you're
gonna see it before I do oh okay
okay warning do not disturb while I'm
watching markiplier serious injury or
death may occur YouTube has a pause
button I don't condone this people may
think that I'm like a cult leader this
is the kind of evidence to suggest that
my videos are not then Morton that you
would be willing to kill someone for the
sake I've not interrupted in my video if
anyone has parsed this video during
watching it
a secure strike team is already on route
to your house you've made your mistake
not time to bury you anyway number two
Bob 0:03
you have to share with your friends well
this next bumper sticker yeah yeah so if
you see a Tesla with one of these
stickers you know it's me you know it's
me someone put this into Photoshop
someone actually designed this or
Illustrator or whatever I don't care but
someone actually designed this I didn't
look I assume there's probably like this
exact same design and instead of
markiplier just sounds like TV shows and
I didn't look but I assume this does
look like a template yeah I thought I
was special
I mean your face isn't it really fine
yeah no I'm there it's it's a someone
else's fan art of me so they probably
stole from two people movin on
I think this whole video is like you
know if they're gonna crop it oh yeah
yeah definitely look if your guys are
ripping off of me then I'm gonna rip off
of you I'm using this purely for profit
what a glow on it the prophecy we know
why God is good
what kind of sacrilege you walk into a
church with this you'll burst into flame
doesn't at all it doesn't fit at all
that's hilarious good to know I can wear
my hat oh good no I can wear my love of
Jesus wherever I go in this lovely
circle it is that right it's a rainbow
in the back I don't know if that
necessarily means pride but you guys can
assume it by the Jesus that it probably
is no one's more prideful than Jesus all
right we got this bad boy why would this
be a thing poverty why would they do
this who's watching yeah she really is I
don't have a knife oh my shovel
that's Julie it's not worth it I'm too
lazy use the cross as a knife you say
makes sense oh it's perfect
thanks Jesus it's well I didn't even get
this yeah yeah this really suck as a
knife didn't I just go through that side
with the scissors I'm pretty sure I did
100% I did that I went through that with
the scissors doing here here we are
what could be I'm just gonna amend and
make a wild guess
is that what it is is that what it is
is that what it is Amy Captain Marvel
more you know I don't mind this at all
I don't mind this this is great if
you've ever fell in this like good job
this is horrifying almost sliced my eye
off that came so close to my eyeball all
this knockoff stuff is old like it's
almost as if I peaked in this era and
ever since then I've been slowly going
downhill and slowly clinging on to the
desperate fringes left of Mike former
glorious man babe look at me in my
heyday with my youth my youth am i any
different than them
am I better with age like a fine wine
okay I can't drink wine in
big [ __ ] hit alright so not only does
markiplier get knocked off okay not only
does markiplier get knocked off but we
miss honest my other channel which if
you don't know about it you only have so
much time left to look into it go to
Hoonah saunas on youtube and check out
some of the content that we have made
before it all gets deleted and it will
exactly this many days so check it out
but we have some oh there's more than
one yeah we have some unas honest merch
nope
look at this classic merch
boo boo it's always Gildan I know my my
stuff Gildan is a very cheap brand it's
probably one of the cheapest that's why
a lot of people use it it's not the best
quality because it's the cheapest you
can get this this hoodie cost like four
bucks five bucks maybe take it all the
profit subscribe to it when it's honest
[Music]
this was made on a phone you can tell
this is finger drawn someone made this
on a phone that's a first
but like alongside like the actual
across eBay and Amazon weird I mean it's
fine like I get it like the day that's
cool whatever it's Frank but it looks
like garbage someone made this on their
phone they didn't even have the common
courtesy to go to photo shop on a
desktop I mean I kinda liked it I guess
but if we're right it shows like just
like I didn't even bother getting up to
rip off of their design if you please
reach out I'm so curious yeah you you
did this from your phone I can tell I
don't know what program used but
something that could save transparent
but this is so clear even battery was
done with a mouse and I don't know
what's more insulting this really seems
like someone went it's like this is
capitalized this is not there's so many
questions what were you doing how much
hustle do you have because if it's
everywhere you have a lot but if you
made it on your phone you have very
little
what are you fascinating just peer
fascinating I am fascinated by that oh I
thought it was a doormat so we can
always look up directly at your taint
the first time you step out of his
shower if there ever was a purpose to
dishonest this was it to end up on a
bath mat I've never contemplated scene
thought of merch to be on a bath mat
that is so fascinating to me was this
printed it must have be printed right it
must be pretty but this is a really
nice-looking print like it's stunning
that ink penetrates very deep into the
fibers and get it's holding its pattern
very well what is the technology that
made this it's really fascinating right
I'm not crazy I think it just came into
existence it's like a cursed object you
stepped out of your shower and you look
down yoo-hoo oh this is fascinating
I'm not even insulted by this because
it's such a different thing in the
technology to make it its own present to
me how do you do this it's not screen
printing I know that for a fact this is
not a screen print how do you do this
how this is in a machine in it just like
the shading on his face how did you do
this that's what I want to know how is
this made I mean I'm gonna use this I
don't have a bathmat right now just been
using a towel on the ground I'm just
going to use this so fascinating I don't
even know if this qualifies as knockoff
merch because it's usually I'm like if I
see just someone take a screenshot of
the video and that's what this is or
that's the thumbnail that video and just
put it on an object I'm like lazy this
blows my mind I'm still gonna sue you
what this blows my mind I when were in
court I'm gonna I'm gonna be like
you're mine give me your money like
that's what I'm gonna be like oh wow wow
wow
okay well I mean of all the things to
cap off this knockoff merch I mean this
has got to be there's got to be the the
King this is like the Cadillac of
knockoff merch does not mean I condone
it in any way shape or form you'll be
hearing from my lawyers but that's
pretty cool
I think someone's relevancy is entirely
defined by how many knock off items
exist of them on the Internet I think we
can all agree on that the fact that unas
honest is bringing a new resurgence in
that only solidifies myself as being a
relevant person on the internet and for
that I am grateful and I'm so glad that
now vs.2014 me has a team of lawyers
ready and willing I don't actually it's
just it's just like two guys they're
nice listen if you make knockoff merch
that is just a rip of the merch that
I've already made her have made in the
past
stop don't don't do that the stuff I
sell on markiplier calm is for charity
look in the past even a lot of those
designs have a lot of people cherish
those were for charity and you taking
those designs and you're selling it for
profit
that's scummy and it's wrong so stop
that if you've got fan ER on a red
bubble like I really honestly have no
problem with that I'm not condoning this
is not a declaration to say like hey go
do whatever you want on red mobile like
I can't legally say that but honestly
like don't take the designs that were
sold for charity
put them up okay glad we're all on the
same page here lawyers will be finally
new soon and I will be coming after you
in any way shape or form all of your
assets will be mine are we burning all
the money that I received from you to
fuel my hunger my warm my house my
furnace will be stuffed to the brim love
your money
oh I don't know how do I end this
oh no I'm being sucked into the ground
it's not a good Astra